leaving Z burger should have been the
final leg of their journey towards a new
life but by the time they went through
this terminal the 39 victims were dying
or already dead lorry drivers who used
this Belgian port regularly are appalled
but not surprised this driver told me
checks are completely inadequate well
when you're going through all the
scanners the probing to try and detect
humans in there are y ver and this
seemed to just get through the dark it's
not picking them up whether they're your
x-ray machine sufficient enough I don't
know I don't believe in this church hall
close to the port migrants are given
dinner every evening they all want to
get to Britain but are afraid and don't
want us to show their faces some have
paid people smugglers to get this
investigators don't yet know if the 39
victim's boarded the container here in
Belgium or elsewhere the broker has been
highlighted in the past by the UK border
force as a key port being used by
migrants just last year both Belgian
officials and the National Crime Agency
raised concerns that increasing numbers
of people are using this route to try to
enter Britain illegally people here find
migrants sleeping on boats in the
shipyards and anywhere they can stay
warm and dry this father and son showed
me round the disused warehouses behind
their restaurant
[Music]
sometimes they sleep either
they make food you see it's people
smugglers and it's it's like very safe
haven for them in zebra
so they come all the way from anywhere
in the world and then they come passing
here the lure of life in Britain has
attracted many thousands to risk the
journey and yet authorities still seem
unable to prevent loss of life on an
appalling scale Becky Johnson Sky News
zoo burger in Belgium